the first thing when you coming to boot
camp right before it they give you a
webpage where you can choose your own
phone your own UNIX name and laptop so
on the first day you already have a
computer that's ready with a dev server
that's dedicated to it what does that
mean it means that now that I've chosen
my year and they had me like a name on
the shelf my computer doesn't have
anything on it I don't have to set up
anything or install anything I just have
a dev server I connect to with SSH and
all the code is there so basically from
working on web development on
dub-dub-dub
I don't clone any repo and I don't
install anything it's already ready for
me to go on and have some impact so I
can access it with SSH in terminal I can
choose to do everything from terminal of
course but we also use as an IDE atom
and also nuclide which is an open source
packages as Facebook develops has a
feature of remote connection so
basically I'm working on my own IDE and
I don't even feel that it's actually
sinking with the server the whole time
but what what's more interesting is that
when I want to use my web browser to go
to the dev server I take my UNIX name
which is on Benna I add the dot SB to it
dot sandbox so if I want to take
facebook.com and go to the dev server
version of it I just take the run Benna
SB and I put it in there and if it's
messenger comm then I squish that in
there and it's just the development
environment that I have at the moment
so out of the box there's no set of
being done it's all done remotely when
there are upgrades to the server or
changes to it I don't have to have my
laptop even on I just get an email
saying that there's maintenance being
done and off hours so it's super
convenient
I have remote access from anywhere so if
I'm using my own browser it doesn't
really matter what browser it is that
URL I showed you before I can take from
my phone and I can test it I can take
that URL and I can share it with someone
else in the team so they can try out my
new feature doesn't have to do with my
laptop it's super convenient it's using
remote resources so my computer's CPU
memory and disk space are irrelevant and
also it's pretty much a lot more secure
so if I misplace my computer all I have
to do is revoke the remote access and
then I don't have to fear anything and I
know what you're thinking that if I have
to have internet connection in order to
work then what happens if I don't have
an internet connection and you're right
and it does sometimes happen but from my
experience it's just not in it's a
non-issue all these things that I get
from it by having a dev server are
really amazing so let's go on to the
next one something that's being talked
not only Facebook does it something
called mono repo Google does it Twitter
does it also Etsy and digitalocean from
what I know basically when we have
projects and we have dependencies
between them we usually use sub models
and we use micro services but here I'm
on a rope repos simply means that
everything is under one file tree so if
I want to create a new project I just
create a new folder or a new file and
that's all it takes
it's a conscious choice that companies
make and I want to tell you about some
of the gains from that approach now I've
seen videos and articles on mono repos
advantages and disadvantages you can go
and see and deep dive into it I just
want to show you a few upsides that I
feel as a developer
the first is code sharing since it's all
one project all the classes all the
methods all the utils are accessible so
there's less chance of code duplication
and reimplementation of the same code
also team collaboration is really really
easy since everyone's codes is
accessible so I can search for something
and it searches the whole code base code
mods which is short for code
modifications if we want to maybe a
refactor the whole code base we can do
that in a single operation for instance
if the performance team thinks that we
should move to a new way
of creating arrays that are more
performant they don't have to talk to
any person on the project they just do
it themselves and they do it in a single
operation knowing that there was no
chance of ruining builds or tests
because it's just like landing any
change and they don't have to worry
about backwards compatibility at all
another thing is bug fixing part of the
culture of Facebook is that you can
touch on anything and you're expected
not to wait for others if it's not
necessary so if I use some someone
else's code and it has a bug in it or
maybe I want to augment it I don't have
to ask him to do it I can do it myself
and then maybe I can add them as a
reviewer and make sure that nothing
breaks when I do it
so committing codes and you want to push
it into production we used with
something we called ifs basically if I'm
starting my day I started with in
terminal artpool which basically fetches
all the updates on the repo and rebase
is my current branch i perfect my
changes and i let's say i want to take
the blue bar on top and i want to change
it to green because i think it's gonna
bring more attention or something then I
use mercurial for it HG commits just
like git and then I arced if it starts
some pre commit validations creates a
fully request call it called the diff
and everything went well it's gonna spew
out this URL with that ID of the diff so
if I click on it I'm gonna see this web
tool and this diff web tool where I can
see everything inside of it the author
is me
I chose maybe my own team to be
reviewers or individuals I think can
contribute to the discussion about this
diff I'm like automatically new
strengths that come into the project are
auto-detected so basically that kicks
off the whole translation process and I
can click a button to to make that
happen
builds and tests if I break anything
like sanity test unit tests I'm gonna
see it here
same goes for lens and there's gonna be
a real big green button saying ship it
if it was accepted and if i click 'ok i
can see the whole landing process right
in front of me in this view so i'm gonna
scroll a bit up
there's the summary this is where we put
in everything that has to do with why we
chose to implement it in this specific
approach so that the review is we know
why i chose this and for prosperity and
also a test plan what they have to do to
are to patch it so they can reproduce it
themselves and what exactly they need to
test and of course putting in unit tests
and webdriver tests and the whole
shebang so i blurred out the code you
can't watch it i'm sorry but you know
what this is this is where we do the
discussions on all kinds of parts of the
code and eventually we are either
comment on it or we request changes or
we approve the diff and before we click
on ship it we make sure that links pass
tests pass the translations are ready or
people are going to see the default
english which is not good we have the
responsibility of putting in logs logs
to make sure that we're not breaking
anything once we hit production and also
logs to make sure that the feature is
actually going out into production and
kill switches we put that in then we can
kill it immediately if the experiment is
over or if we see that something went
wrong so we use something called feature
gating when we release something into
production we have a very useful tool
for that so basically once a feature is
ready and you want to turn it on or off
or decide on exposure percentage you can
put it as conditions in the code so if
you want to expose a feature only to
Americans then you have that inside or
maybe if you want to expose a certain
promotion from someone who came in from
the homepage you'd have that there or
maybe just have a kill switch but having
all that in the code is cumbersome it's
it takes hours to propagate into
action and you have very limited
visibility so instead we let separate
configuration do that for us so all I
have to do in the code is ask gate
keeper this is my feature should it be
on or off so it just spews out bullion
and in another configuration tool which
is called gate keeper I can do something
like this I can say I want 100% exposure
to users with these IDs so basically I'm
gonna be the only one that sees this or
maybe I want to open the feature up to
all of the corporate IP devices but for
public only 10% and then I can do it
incrementally until it gets to a hundred
percent if everything goes well maybe I
can take a look at the query string and
I want ref to be homepage and only then
the feature is up and one last example
is I want this feature open only for
Opera Mini and touch devices so I can
stack them I can have them one over the
other and it's super super convenient
and it propagates into production in a
matter of minutes so if I want to kill
something if I want to up something if I
want to change the conditions it's all
in config it doesn't take hours to land
and I love it
doc fooding doc fooding refers to the
process of allowing internal beta
testing from actual employee devices
this is not like a Facebook thing a lot
of people use this a lot of companies
but it means that you're not using a
test device to test stuff you don't have
to install certain builds if you want to
test beta builds or experimental
features we use gatekeeper on the
products that are all installed on
employees devices so as developers even
before it hits production we can get
signals on health logs crash reports
even to see if metrics go the right way
from thousands of devices and platforms
very early on in the development stage
and since this is not a face with made
concept nor is it a corporate related
solution
even at my previous company which we
were maybe only a few dozens of
developers and we had a small beta group
of testers we set up dogfooding and got
valuable feedback very very early on so
I encourage you to do that if you can
now in a company that aspires to move so
fast communication is really really
important so sharing information for
that email will just not cut it so
instead we each have an employee profile
in a kind of an internal Facebook called
workplace this is publicly available as
an enterprise solution for companies
basically means that it's Facebook for
work I can create groups internal events
I have mentions I can have BOTS I can
make the whole thing searchable and at
Facebook we take groups to the extreme
we have groups for features for products
for technologies and I don't have to
really be a member of that team to be a
member of the group and we encourage
that if I am really interested in
reactive VR but I'm not working on it I
can just subscribe to that group and see
the whole discussion also I can be a
beta tester on groups so only when you
subscribe to a certain group then
suddenly that feature is exposed to you
and then you're part of the discussion
as a forcing function and it's
incredible but also we have groups for
all kinds of things for coffee lovers
for movie buffs for sports fanatics and
it's all searchable because somebody
already asked it's at some point and
it's super convenient we have a lot of
celebrations at Facebook visitors that
come in do Q&A zand tech talks we have
posts for visitors that come to TLV so
they're not strangers when we walk by
them and to initiate conversations if
someone had a face versary an
anniversary at Facebook we have like a
balloon celebrating that and we post it
to everyone and we instant message each
other on a daily basis with messenger
for for work basically instant messaging
is a legit way to contact
to anyone no matter what the seniority
we can talk about anything and I've done
this a million times if someone said
something at Q&A that rubbed me the
wrong way I am still messaging and we
talk about it anybody at leadership
anybody who's interesting if there's a
feature that I really want to know about
I can contact anyone and it's very very
legitimate and it still amazes me one
last thing about communication is
something that we call hbm's it's a
tradition at Facebook that you're it's
not a requirement it's not a must but we
do that in in my development team
basically HBM is highlights people and
me
it's a periodical post that you put into
a specific group where you talk about
highlights what I've done this week with
links or images that have to do with it
what I plan to do next week people new
people that came into the team and maybe
I want to share some private stuff from
my own personal life and that's
basically what I do it's important so
that everyone in the company is
up-to-date on anything that has any
value because you get so many groups so
many notifications this kind of sums up
what happened this week with you and
with the product that you're following
and it's really handy to have it as a
history log like a chronological log of
whatever you did since you came into the
company
next up is hackathons I don't have to
tell you what it is of course we do this
in every engineering site several times
a year we see it as an opportunity to
let employees touch on anything at
Facebook you can put your tasks aside
for a day or two and you can experiment
with anything so I tried I added
features to messenger I did some work on
internal tools I did some stuff for
hackathon tooling as well I did a lot of
stuff that didn't work eventually but it
doesn't matter
I tried new technologies it's all legit
we do have a theme but you're not
imposed to follow it it's rich in swag
there's food there's a celebration and
there's a show-and-tell at the end of
the week and sometimes some of the
projects are even
presented in front of mark and
leadership and flew intial people in the
company this is from a livestream that
from Facebook headquarters in Menlo Park
a year ago where ohad an engineer on the
Facebook light team in Tel Aviv
demonstrated this hack and one last
thing it's one of the beautiful aspects
of the hackathons is that there is no
hackathon organizer at Facebook
basically it's led by a group of
employees and the employee if it's an
engineer a designer whoever wants to be
a part of it makes it happen that's a
bit that's it on hackathons there is
another hackathon ish thing that we call
fixer thongs basically knowing that the
company strives for impact that means
that sometimes your code is suboptimal
there's that hard coded thing that you
put in there that you know you wanted to
change sometime but you never got to it
stuff that's not optimal in performance
or just ugly code that you don't want
anybody to ever see so basically we have
this week it could be called a fix Athan
or a tech tech week where you put
everything aside and you either as an
individual or as a team you go for
something in the code that you wanted to
change for a very long time or stuff
that's legacy and you wanted to remove
it now people that knew about what I'm
going to talk about said that you know
if I talk only about things that I love
then it's gonna look kind of weird so
you know and asked me to talk about
something I don't love and sometimes
they don't have that brand of coffee
that I'm used to and I have to wait
until they replenish it but on that
there's something called on-call shifts
now there is no way that anyone would
say that they love on-call shifts let me
fill you in on how this works basically
it's impossible to push safely to
production so frequently without having
a solid safety net and one of the
biggest problems that I experienced
especially in the previous company where
I was in charge of automation is that
the people that were in charge of
monitoring
there was a huge disconnect between them
and the people that actually worked on
the product and maintained and monitored
it so the disconnect makes it really
hard for dashboards to stay relevant for
people to actually be available when
something needs their attention and not
having a true point of contact when some
other teams need some clarification
about code or about the product so at
Facebook every team creates and
maintains their own dashboards their own
alerts we set the thresholds and define
the severity of them and basically we
have rotation between us on a week where
we put everything aside and we're just
monitoring and where the point of
contact and maybe we take some low-end
some stuff from the log and we use them
as tasks or us
so for instance if I let's say I find a
bug on reactions on the reaction feature
I can post about it in the reactions
feedback group and let them know but if
this is something critical and nothing
at Facebook is somebody else's problem
then I can actually use a tool to see if
someone already ported it I can see
who's the uncle for that specific
feature at that time and I can instant
message him and see if if he's available
and if not I can assign the task that's
severe and I know exactly who to assign
it to because someone is on call on that
team last thing about feedback one of
the things that always bothered me as a
professional was when the notion of a
team member of view always God
deprioritized
I had this in every company I was in
that you just want to know that you're
okay
and you want to know what you can
improve on and you want a basis of
telling that to someone else or even the
company so but there's always something
more important to focus on and it always
gets backlogged so Facebook puts
tremendous effort into allowing --get
employees to give and get feedback on a
regular basis in multiple ways I'm gonna
say all of them just two of them one is
employee company twice a year
the company asks for anonymous feedback
as through a survey that sent to all
employees it does this in order to
achieve precise and up-to-date
evaluation of how the company feels
about itself you're being asked about
the products about the mentality about
visibility communications the state of
mind benefits and also hardships and
also we have the notion of peer to peer
reviews where I can ask someone twice a
year there's a block for it where I can
ask people that I work with all over the
company to give me a review I want to
know what I can improve on and we all
encourage ourselves to communicate
anything that we see valuable so we can
be our best and it does so with tons of
respect and with great great intentions
so that's it for my talk I love talking
about Facebook I want you to come over
I'm gonna be at the booth please don't
talk to me about policy stuff or world
domination but I do want to talk about
everything that has to do with
engineering anything that has to do with
recruiting and we are looking for really
really good people especially front-end
developers let's talk about culture
about the internal country at Facebook
and also anything that has to do with
the mission and the vision I'm kind of
the guy to talk to you about that thank
you very much
[Applause]